[Music]
one four four
i would like to say just before we start
start start
that i do believe you lied
okay um about not knowing who
i was before i
i mean here's the thing i haven't seen
your show
which one which one which one
um i couldn't tell you i'm so sorry
have you not seen of mine um
i couldn't tell you because i do you
want my coffee with my hair in it
i i wouldn't mind i've definitely sipped
worse coffee
um yeah so i
hadn't seen any of your shows um
and when i received the
you know communication why did you
respond to my dm at all because you
weren't following me
um like what was it that
i mean you check your dms once a day
once a week
i actually check my dms pretty um often
because
i'm more often than not i'm getting
people reaching out to me from the
innocence community or like for instance
next week i'm going to be taking part of
this death
row like panel thing where like
i don't know if you knew this but like
trump is accelerating a lot of federal
executions
um right now um he's like before he
leaves office he's trying to like get a
bunch of people executed because he
doesn't think the next administration is
going to follow through
um and anyway i'm going to be taking the
only reason i'm taking part in this
panel and is because people reached out
to me and said hey we're trying to get
the word out about
this guy is about to be executed he did
a horrible crime but he was 19 years old
and like we're trying to you know even
if he spends the rest of his life in
prison like let's
try to save his life what's the
difference between prison and jail so
jail is
where you go pre-conviction
um so it's where you're held while
people are trying to figure out what the
hell to do with you
and then once you're convicted you are
convicted to either
maximum security prison minimum security
prison and they're a
vast array of different kinds of prisons
that you can be sent to um
and prison is where you go to stay and
serve your sentence
so and then in italy it's different
because
i mean i don't even actually know if
they have a difference between
jail and prison they probably do for men
but for women just because
women are not the people who are usually
going to prison we're
a much smaller portion of the population
we're basically being sent
to the extra facilities that were
originally meant for men
and they're just not equipped for us and
was yours
was all women yes yeah yeah i mean well
so my portion of the prison so like the
whole prison complex had
a facility for men but it was on the
other side of like this big
open field and what would happen
is like women would sort of develop
relationships with men across that
bridge by like
waving towels through the bar
windows and um like lighting you can
tell many a time they would like
communicate with lighters
they would literally be like doing like
a morse code with lighters
yeah just to like have a connection i
always fantasize about dating guy in
prison because you know where he is and
he can't cheat on you
that's a whole thing that's for when i'm
on your podcast
um so it's obviously impossible to know
where to start especially with my
brain but like if you were me what would
you want my first question to be because
like you go in interviews and ever
and like you've just had to answer so i
don't want to ask you anything you've
already been asked
i appreciate that um no i appreciate
that because that's something that
i as an interviewer also try to do like
whenever i talk to someone i
try to go and see whatever interviews
they've already done yeah
and like see what have they been asked a
million times i'm gonna veer
very far away from actual journalism um
right
i mean the thing that like people never
ask me about
is um or even like don't really ask me
seriously about they'll be like what are
you doing today
um but it's like i'm actually doing a
lot of stuff today like
so um what are you doing now yeah cop um
but yeah just like all of the the work
that i'm doing with my
my husband chris and uh here who is
my nemesis um
and i you know i'm a lot of the work
that i do is super informed
by everything that i went through but
it's this ongoing battle of trying to
um not only like make the best of a bad
situation and just like take what i've
learned and like put it to a good cause
but also to like just
be my own person in a world that wants
me to be something i'm not going to talk
about your process of
getting uh deciding what to wear on
camera
well i saw you in the um
documentary that someone was like that
was amanda's documentary
the one where you're in the pink shirt
boat neck shirt yes
and they're like that was amanda's like
side of the story like i don't know
how that happened but someone's like
that was like her documentary and i was
like oh cool she like made her own
to set the record straight and i was
like okay cool and then i was like oh
wow but it's so it felt very
fair yeah no i mean i definitely like it
was a
embarrassing in many ways for me i mean
my biggest problem with it is
well as they say in the industry like
they can't claim
journalistic integrity if they're paying
the people
that say like not paying women for their
work is well they didn't pay
anyone so it should be fair
did they pay the journalist nick pisa i
didn't i was a
i understood that no one was i will stop
the podcast right now
i don't think they paid anyone who was
on camera but
everyone i know saw it so no like the
way that um
it was approached to me and like i
completely understood um
was for the sake of it not being
an amanda knox i'm sorry i just want to
talk about your shirt oh my shirt
oh okay because i looked at you and i
was like she's not wearing makeup she's
not
she's wearing a pink shirt
she can't wear anything but this yeah so
um the decision of what to wear on
camera interestingly
is something you have to have anxiety
about but also at the s
at the same time it was like a last
minute thing like literally
my best friend was like bringing me to
the weird cold
warehouse where they had that like
gorgeous backdrop that's like actually
25 where you shot it where it was shot
yeah yeah it was like in a
warehouse um they got a location fee
um and um and i don't know i
must have been wearing like something
with a collar or something and they were
like we just need to keep it simple we
need to like have people be just looking
at your
face and not remember being like is she
wearing a strapless bra is this a
bandeau
situation like it's just that's always
my first second and third
but like clear bra straps
um god was that no you were in prison
yeah is that a thing
there was like a bra strap where you'd
have like a clear little piece of tape
which it's clear is not clear if you had
seen my last special you would know i
did a whole joke about clear bra shot
but you're not a fan and i it makes me
like
sorry we we we made sure to watch a
special before we came but you saw which
one you know you did i don't know i saw
the one with the sex doll
[Laughter]
well they were like she's kind of funny
um i have lots of regrets about that
speaking of regrets
uh how was italy that's what by the way
strong is one of my best friends she's
on snl and she's there's so many people
that are fascinated with you and i have
this
theory i'm working on that you
are a lot of the people that were
in their 30s when this
rigmarole happened to you grew up on
amanda chase from my so called life
um lisa loeb stay
which i sang to you while making eye
contact with you last night
um who else did i show you last night
allison williams
allison brie
[Music]
i went to high school with her
that the girl everyone wanted
the enigma the enigmatic gorge
i know i don't i mean it's i'm not happy
about it um
the projection machine and i remember
when this was all happening
i was like at like trying to get agents
or may i thought going to parties would
get you jobs or something and so i would
go to these like
parties like when i was like 22 in
hollywood trying to like get someone to
cast me i didn't know how it worked um
i'm like do i fuck
will someone just can i blow someone for
a job like i didn't know how to do it
um and i heard people talking about you
and it was a bunch of guys just being
like she's legit
gorgeous and just being like
talking about you you me i thought when
you were telling me about this i thought
they were talking about you
conversation now
this is the first time i thought you i
thought you're weird also he wasn't
gorgeous back then
no i wasn't like so this is the thing
that like always like you know
this is gorgeous now okay well love you
for the right right answer but
you're right she's way hotter right now
than she was
10 years ago okay but at the time
like this is this is also like the
bizarre thing to me like okay people
made a big deal about like foxy noxie
and like she's the girl that everyone
wants and it's like that if your name
didn't rhyme with foxy would this be as
big of a story
uh no um and so
again like at the time that was not me
like i was not walking around the world
being like oh
i'm the prettiest girl in the room like
that that never occurred to me and also
i was never
treated that way you're the prettiest
but also the most enigmatic
and like also that's weird to me your
eyebrows
your eyebrows are a problem um
sorry i'm i'm texting a couple
neuroscientists asking them
why our brains love a rhyme
foxy noxie why'd it like why is that
clickbait why does the why do the
tabloids love that
you know and did it rhyme in italian so
in italian um they what they would
say like they would translate foxy noxi
into volpe kativa which means evil evil
fox
um and so like they it it always
translate like the translation
sort of twisted into like the the volpe
forba the
the cunning you know the cunning fox so
the
so the girl who's like a master
manipulator
um i was not an enigmatic person i think
i mean we've spent a few days together
and it's like
i'm i'm a very open book all the time
um i'm alive um but i'm also like i'm
just kind of here and i've always just
been kind of here and when i was in
perugia like
i was very openly like just wearing boy
clothes all the time
well and then like you know doing yoga
and playing guitar and like there was
nothing i was like
everyone was like she didn't react the
way i wanted her to
right the beautiful girl didn't grieve
the way
i wanted her to grieve even though i
know nothing about the situation
and yes and that's and this was also
filtered primarily through
the italian media first and foremost
which was
women are hysterical and here i am
by sylvia berlusconi at the time yes
it's run by silvio brothers
100 plug by accident
i i just happened to that this is such
an interesting confluence and i feel so
like lucky that the universe is ep the
show
um like that learning about how
the television airwaves are owned by the
same person that runs the government
and how women are portrayed in
particular by that particular person
that's a business news is a business
news is a business um
fake news fake news was a big thing like
i'm surprised that
more people haven't made the connection
between berlusconi and trump
because they're echoes of each other no
i mean they're not only friends but
it's he wrote i mean putin kind of wrote
the playbook
but then berlusconi kind of wrote the
playbook for trump and like putin does
it in
his in a different way like yeah like
exactly but like that's my favorite part
but he's also like used to be secret
service and like he's
you know a military guy meanwhile
berlusconi and
trump are both entertainers oh yeah
they're
entertaining uh berlusconi was a singer
and we forget that trump
was the biggest television star in
america at the time the apprentice was
the biggest show on tv we forget it
he didn't show up to the debates
remember and they moved the debates or
something for he just
knows how to i have a whole i know we
got a whole thing about this the other
night chris that i think he misspells
his tweets on purpose
i think everything's like so calculate
like he just he reads at an eighth grade
level
but i also think he reads robert greene
i also think he reads
do you think he reads though but we're
why do i have amanda knox on the podcast
and we're talking about donald trump
actually this is why he's this
invitation why this invitation
this is why we're fucking talking about
him it's unreal
yeah shame on yeah we don't eat up to
you you've had enough shame i think
thanks well i don't know i mean your
braces i've never had braces
that's ir see that's like i've also
never had uneven boobs
i was actually afraid to bring that up
i know
but
what if you're on a little bit of a peg
like but here's the thing
even at the time in perugia i've always
had a butt that didn't fit my body
and like my butt crack would be like
coming out
you've got a the natasha legero
esther pavitsky um
there are what's your your german german
yeah
see it's why you should be birthing you
should have just
said that i wanted you to feel like i
have german ancestry i don't know what
to tell you we can see horrible things
and like to
do cartwheels no truly i mean even just
like talking to my oma
about like her what's oma is grandma
grandma yeah my
oma like her mom had a bomb drop on her
and then her own
mother her own grandmother who took care
of her afterward tried to drown her in a
bathtub
like my oma talks about like these
tragic things that happened in her life
like oh yeah you know whatever you know
like whatever and then like for me
i get deer in headlight syndrome where
like something like i've never had
anything bad happen to me until
the bad thing happened to me and i was
like
i could not process and so i just sort
of did what
by the way you don't even know what you
did well indeed and indeed it depends on
who
says what i did what because like who
remembers what i did
who thinks they saw what i did people
didn't see me cry or they did see me cry
they forgot if they saw me
cry they thought it was suspicious that
they saw me cry like
i honestly think that a ton of
confirmation bias goes into all of this
because people just
again you become a workshop test exactly
and i also we
um i'm so impressed that we haven't said
we've talked about these yet we haven't
really done that yet which one um
said like and we've already talked about
this okay you know that
remember when i was like let's see let's
not do the how much we're rehashing
how we've had slumber parties um
i would my dog frank
who i think you know uh is my world
yeah sorry mona um she's right there
when he can hear you when he went uh cut
to
three tendons and three arteries and
there was just blood
when you see blood did you see blood no
whoa whoa i didn't
know that people don't know that did you
know that
no no emily i did not know that did you
know that chris
so there was like so i like i saw
like here's what i saw in my bathroom
there were like
three shit there were three spots of
blood in the sink three spots of blood
and then like there was shit in the
other bathroom in the documentary and so
like
i and then there's weirdly more
disturbing in an odd way and actually
there was like a like a dark splotch
um which of something that turned out
like that turned out to be blood on the
bath mat but again it wasn't like
your dog i saw that video where there's
like fucking blood everywhere and it's
like
horrifying i showed amanda video of my
dog bleeding which i put on my instagram
stories
for all you guys because i will stop at
nothing to get attention
um and uh opposite of you um
and you started crying i mean
at eight a.m this morning yeah no i i
i've seen him in an ox cry
frank made her cry so and i and my
instinct was to video it how
fucked up is that so here's here's what
that would have been chris
would that have been exploited of well
did you get her consent
i would have done it and then i would
have said can i put this
in the podcast so it's like post factum
consent yeah i i
what i do is i just take footage in
b-roll in case
sure so here's the fucked up thing i
like to have options as you might have
noticed
i didn't see a thing about like i didn't
see
meredith's body i didn't see into her
room where the whole like blood
everywhere like i never saw any of that
and then in prison like after i'd been
there a while
my lawyer comes in and he's like hey i
just need to like
walk you through a little bit of like
the autopsy photos so you can like
point me out like not the autopsy photos
like the crime scene photos so you can
tell me like
if you've seen this before or this
before and so i was like okay and so
he's like flipping through these photos
and and then like one photo is just like
meredith
and um and
i lost it because i had not seen her yet
like i hadn't seen her with her wound
and i lost it and like i was in
hysterics and my
lawyer was like oh my god and then i
like they had to take me out
and then the warden was like what the
what what is wrong with you like
and i was like they showed me her body
and she was like you've seen her body
before
and i was like no i haven't i have not
seen that i did not know
and like um anyway like
it's just like the things that people
assumed about how my reaction should be
based upon what they thought i knew
like anyway um
i'm so sorry to make you have to talk
about it i i'm sorry
i brought you here to talk about it i
mean no i'm i'm really happy that you
brought me here i just want you to
be done with this well i'm done i'm
bored
i mean like it's just like i i just
think you have
some there's so many more interesting
things about you but i feel like in some
way you've been like
chosen to reveal something you're not
the first person who said that to me
before um
well i have changed
a business model that was
changed by joe rogan first
he knows that you love it he's just like
i love
like it's like i see like when he met me
beat the fuck out of me yeah he met me
and he gave me back rubs and recited
poetry to me he met you and he
was like yeah i love it i love it i love
it
i don't feel like a girl around me i
don't feel like
when people i don't feel like people
treat me with kid gloves which
it was so interesting our um
interaction so i dm'd you and i was like
come on it was like a
just like a hail mary i just was like i
i
because on this podcast i only want to i
cannot pretend to be interested in
people i just
i truly can't um and uh
i don't have people on then i'm gonna
just be like hey so what that was weird
like i it's like tourette's or something
um and i felt a little did you feel wary
of me
no because i felt like we were like you
were like here's
i dm'd you're like here's my email and i
was like
great here's my the chain
and then we were on email and then i was
like can i ask her for her number to
tech
like we were all very and now that i
know you i think that's just your
demeanor you're just
have boundaries in your secure
attachment strategy
style well it's actually literally
because i'm terrible at answering my
phone and so i'm afraid of giving people
my phone number because
okay so here's the one sort of like me
being terrified of the world is like i
actually don't like answering my phone
i don't like it when people call me and
i don't recognize the number because
no one does because i've literally been
put on the spot by like tabloid
journalists who've somehow found my
number
and they call me and they're like can
you like i want a statement right now
about this like thing and i'm like
uh and like i just it feels very
aggressive whereas it's like i know that
like if i receive an email from you
i can like absorb the fact that you're
even talking to me and then i can
respond um who's the most the closest
person to your situation in terms of
walk down the street and everyone is
like
half sympathy half aw half
you never know you never know i was
talking to my friend nikki
on the way over and i was asking her
she's my smartest friend from college um
i said who's like click bait tantamount
to amanda knox like who's the
um and i was like is it monica lewinsky
is that the closest person in terms of
um i think so she said um what about
anna nicole
that's interesting who's mary kay
let's know mary kay letourneau um had
is that the woman who had sex with her
student yeah the problem that's not true
they're guilty
problem with all these allegories is
they all did something they those are
they're guilty and like take lorena
bobbitt for instance
so there's no she's an interesting case
because the domestic violence she
suffered was erased
and the penis chopping was the only
thing anyone talked about right but that
doesn't that event doesn't make sense
without the context of like
years of abuse that's every man's
greatest fear right so to me he still
did something
yeah and it did nothing so like the
parallel breaks concur
to me amanda
the most interesting part of this is
like you're
if you had watched my whole special not
just clips
um like seattle
um crafty lady
um i think that it's like
and i don't i don't mean to get into men
versus women i think i have
it's women and women too i think a lot
of people's worst fear is the
we all know women's power
not i'm not gonna say psychic because
that's clairvoyant
um intuitive whatever ability to
manipulate
um that's why there's no female
magicians
because it's not funny right it's like
when a guy doesn't care like wow
and when a girl when a woman does it
we're like oh like i knew it
you know um so
you're not supposed to trick me you're
supposed to be in service of me i i
already am
and bolin i'm ar you're already have a
pow
you already know something i don't know
and you're making me paranoid and i
can't handle it
your inner power i don't know what
you're thinking i can't read your mind
but you can read mine
and i think there's a little of that
with
you i could see that because i do i do
feel like i tend to enter into a room
and immediately get a read on even just
like
um not including me but like
hierarchies in the room and i'm always
drawn to the person who i feel
like doesn't have as much hierarchy
which usually
um well like underdog but or literally
dogs by the way this is also literally
children
this is enough if you give me permission
i will show
this is um dogs are
know everything and i really want you to
meet my horse and to video it
because who the dog goes if a dog goes
to you you're
you're clear you're good no joke i've
had guys come over and the dog's like
absolutely not and my dog mona who is my
little psychic
witch um i mean
killed some blood vessels in your legs
yes i could i could not like
i had the like oh okay here's my leg
coming back to life amazon
dogs are this was like a pig pile
uh uh pyramid on top of you but i'm just
like willing to be a dog with a dog
like the minute i saw her i was like oh
this dog wants to like be chased around
the yard i don't know who you
are also you don't care kids and dogs
have no idea and it's really nice
because it just means that i can
sort of i am good at recognizing other
people's emotions i like to be
a listener even like even just a
physical listener
like i've been listening i don't know if
you've noticed but i've been listening a
lot to you over the past two days that's
unfortunate but no not in a bad way but
because like i
see that you have a lot to give and so
like i want to be
a receptacle for you and that's like
something that i think that a lot of
women
do is like we are paying attention to
what people need
and so then we try to like fill that
space and be
the space that people need and i'm we're
designed to sort of
i mean it's i think your husband
dave like these are you know i think
we're evolving
um towards something that's more
harmonious and
and kind of copacetic with men and women
but we're kind of designed to be the
women work together like an octopus
in the kitchen and with the kids and
everyone's breastfeeding everybody
else's babies and everyone's the onsen
the system and that's why we have that
intuitive power because we're constantly
communicating
all one organism and
this um sort of next generation of
super-evolved men are starting to kind
of lean into their
quote-unquote feminine qualities and
it's starting to feel a little this is
why i love my relationship with chris
because like
with him i have found an ability to
assert myself that i've
never had in a relationship before
guys look hey it's our first
remote ad isn't that fun
it's so fun i'm having so much fun right
now
very on trend with the with the you know
have to listen to this
if you're listening on audio because you
can see benton's apartment
you can see yeah you can see part of my
kitchen he's also way shinier than me
could it be because of the daily harvest
you're consuming i mean i am consuming a
um a lot of it let me just tell you i
have my favorites right out here really
holding up boxes of daily
look at this isn't it fun wow let's see
if i have any
i love these things they have so many
new things too like i've never had the
the oats before i've never had like the
oatmeal oh that
that my favorite of those bites um what
are they the little like protein bars
yeah i love the little bites too
i love the in the winter times look at
my gross finger oh look are you guys
glad i'm doing this remotely you can see
my mangled finger
i'm holding it up to the camera um uh
lampbreads did you know that no
i cook them right here in my little
toaster oven that you can see if you're
watching not if you're listening
but there's also no my favorite is that
uh chocolate mocha
smoothie uh with kale in it but there's
also something i had when i was sick
over the holiday it was like an ice
cream
yeah it was like a starb i can't even
explain what
it was like uh it's like a it's like ice
cream but
it's almost like soft serve ice cream it
was so good
it was soft right away you know how
sometimes you have to wait
oh it drives me nuts and they're all
healthy that's the cool thing about
daily harvest is everything is like
healthy good for you organic vegetables
they come right to your door they
literally come in this is a good new
year's
resolution because can i tell you
something actually
oh look at him holding up his box that's
so cute this is what they sent to my
door it's insulated it stayed cool all
day till i got home
and it was just filled with treats worth
it
wine in the background huh that's amanda
cerny's one
oh it that's really is
i like to support people yeah you do so
you guys i'm just telling you
everyone's busy i understand but
daily harvest like i cannot tell you how
big of a deal is to just go like i have
no time to eat lunch
i'm going to eat this bowl of stuff and
i know all of it
everything is good i don't have to look
at the label i don't have to be feel
guilty about it i don't feel shame
and then i don't have to do math later
like okay i had a little bit of vitamin
c
no and then for dinner i don't know what
to eat because i didn't i ate crappy all
day like it's just like
it's just such a staple it's just like a
game changer i feel like let me just
tell you i wake up i have my latte i
have my oatmeal i have a flatbread for
lunch and there's no dishes and that's
what i'm really into
we got to be using these remotes to you
have you cooking these products and
proving it
i i will i mean i will i'll blend this
up
remotely with benton at home using the
product and i'm in the studio
i literally am obsessed with these foods
they're delicious and then
the cool thing is there's like they
don't use like preservatives or added
sugars or anything
so i don't bloat that's really nice you
can get started today go to
dailyharvest.com
and enter promo code good for you to get
25 off your first box that's promo code
good for you
for 25 off your first box at
dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com nailed it
benton what would you say is my
sort of like favorite hobby
friendship
[Laughter]
what would you say where would you say
spend most of my time
definitely in bed waiting on your golden
ticket
i'm literally like the grandpa in the
chat yeah and you pop right out when
it's time to when it's time to perform
i am here's the thing i used to get so
much shit
for how hard it is to sleep on certain
mattresses and everyone will call me
princess and the pee
and you're so sensitive and you're so
this is like i'm sorry i don't want to
injure myself these messages are
important my dad always said people
uh people hard-working people need two
things a good dinner and a good mattress
you spend a third of your life on that
it now in covid times who knows we're
fucking in bed all day at this point am
i allowed to curse
um this is i cannot i'm so angry that
this
product hasn't always been around you
basically get because i like i'll try
to repeat and i'm like it's too tempting
then i'll try it's like there's just no
i'm an in-betweener
they match this to you you take a
two-minute quiz you tell them how you
sleep your body type
what you prefer and then they match them
your preferences we've been sideways on
certain mattresses
guys telling you i went to a doctor and
he's like the most damage you're doing
your body is in your sleep
i was like i don't know what to do with
that and if he
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine save yourself
injuries
in the long run healer healer healer
it's a healer
the healing helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders that's awesome
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep
pillows i don't have their pillows yeah
they're good pillows too
helix sleep.com whitney
did you date people after you came back
from prison
i've dated on hinge so i
didn't like that it is on bumble oh yeah
i don't even know what he
i thought that was like a hip way of
saying like are you in a relationship
okay no no i've never joined a dating
app tinder never on tinder
um i was afraid of meeting new people i
didn't trust new people
um i mean it was like and i was being
asserted that i couldn't trust new
people so like i would go to
um math class and i went back to school
college yeah i went back to college and
i was taking a remedial math class
in seattle yeah i went to the university
of washington and like i go to math
class and like people are taking
pictures of me in math class and posting
them to like
secretly yes secretly and then posting
them to like their snowboarding buddies
like
you know private like social group thing
not realizing that like
google alerts are a thing and so here i
am like
receiving a google or my step dad
receiving a google alert and being like
dude there's a guy in your class who's
talking about peeing in your butt and
seducing you
like so that he can get pictures of you
and like
and i know that that's a real thing so
such a bummer i just like what ended up
happening was i
i went back to what i knew and where i
felt safe and like i
the first person i dated when i came
back was someone i had dated before in
college
and i stayed in my own little bubble
interesting
um what am i looking at i'm sorry the
um we'll talk about it later okay you
know my brain there's just a lot of like
windows my you don't know the habit
so i have a list like a list yes of
things
um that i don't want to
not uh bring up so
your podcast is called labyrinths yes
the fact that it wasn't about the movie
labyrinth was a little
like we're working on that we're working
on that i need to like get so it can't
just be
about a thing no i i am the blue worm
from labyrinth
that's like i should interview you
concur
but in person only okay in person yeah
i was very publicly ashamed i don't know
if you know this but my life has been
very hard
i want to hear about that i mine is more
she's had work done she's skinny she
lies about her
age she's not funny i mean female
comedians are the most
loathed people on the planet yeah you
know the most hated women they do a very
masculine job and
a woman talking for an hour with a
microphone you're like the female
magician like you're just trying to
do and you're not allowed to be allowed
to fuck us or kill us or
or stop us and if someone well you're
doing a kind of magician thing too where
you're like i'm reading your mind
so that i can make you laugh it's a
little bit of a mass hypnosis and it's a
little bit of a blue balls
like i'm we're kind of falling in love
because you're falling in love we're all
falling in love
for an hour i'm trying to make you fall
in love with me for an hour
yeah and then you walk away but i only
so
so this leads me to what is the
difference between women is there any
difference between women and men's
reaction to you
do me you go in the grocery store
i go into the grocery store um more
more often than not it's women who um
who approach me to say like i know you
and i
i cared about your case or whatever but
interestingly it's
more often men who are saying i think
you have something important to say
yeah she gets a lot of the i had a
daughter and
i saw her and you you know from the
women
but the people who um reach out
obsessively
online for instance are usually men yeah
the stalkers are men
yeah yeah well that's normal and they
stalk other people too yeah like
everyone gets talked i know and
chris and i just so you guys know we
have a very like
i come off dismissive about it you know
because he's living in this
you know chinese finger trap of um
but yeah i was just curious and do
people
when you well i think i'm sorry this is
fucked up to say but there's a little
bit of a
i think for
i don't think you're notorious i don't
think you're infamous but just for known
people with the masks now there's a
little bit of like i get to wear a mask
and just like walk into a store and i
don't have to worry about people hating
me
they still recognize they still
recognize me because it's your fucking
eyebrows
i think it might be my eyebrows did you
um i need to find out like who
the who did the study of
that because your eyes are also
incredibly deep set
right and like good luck doing eye
makeup like lucy punch
um who i cast in the female brain can we
um pull up loosey punch they say that
i can do it right here they say that we
evolved
to have our eyes sunken into our head to
take a punch
oh so well i take a emotional punch to
the face which is so
fascinating to me with you because your
eyes are so deep set
yeah um i mean i always thought that
like here people are friends of mine are
doing makeup and i just can't do it
because it just becomes a crease
like hers are so deep sad yeah totally
and they're so gorgeous we did this
movie
and it was like the lighting yeah
it's not the same when you're with her
you know it was like you see her and
then you see in the light and you're
like oh i need to
um i'm just so interested in how our
faces evolved
or our bodies and faces and brains
evolved to manage the
violence and don't forget sweat you know
the brow ridge and the deep set eyes is
also just to keep the sweat and shit out
of your eyes
will you marry me
don't forget sweat
totally german violent working
stoic yep just get like good did you do
yoga were you a gymnast so yes um i
i was a very the regular if you didn't
do
gymnasius i mean i can go outside and do
a run off back handspring for you right
now
if you weren't and you have a clean
chair i haven't seen cheer
but so if you weren't a gymnast i think
it might be weirder to me
sure i mean i i appreciate that i was
the only person who was there doing that
and doing stretches but like
this is where i was regularly doing yoga
like every day
so like to be trapped in a in a police
office where i have to sit in this chair
all day
and like be called and ask the same
questions and like i
just have a different relationship with
my body because i can i know what my
muscles are doing
you know when um you're somewhere in
some republic and there's a guy
who's like imaginary golfing
i don't think i've ever seen that have
you ever seen that he's the golfer when
we go to the golf course i like
jog and then he golfs
but like when you see you never see
someone who's like just a guy who's just
like
does a baseball um that's sketchy as
fuck i'd
that would be weird i'd question that
guy so emily you know when um
you're in a grocery store or something
and you see a guy do an imaginary golf
swing
and they even move their feet this is
real
this is a real thing i mean it's just
like we have our little default
i because i always wanted to do um a
sketch about this
where a guy you know guys will do like
imaginary basketball yes
and that he misses
[Laughter]
that he did it wrong so he has to like
acknowledge it yeah yeah
oh fuck like why did you miss
you couldn't pick anything it's like i
was working this joke and i don't think
it's gonna work about how
um every woman um who lives alone has to
pretend there's an imaginary man in
their house when a worker comes over
and you're kind of like and the man that
you pick says so much about
who's your imaginary man i imagine
you've got a lot of workers in the house
my imaginary man like when i because i
got
burgled um at an apartment yeah my life
has been
hard that's scary no no uh years and
years ago
when you were in prison i was getting
burgled okay well it was
it was stressful that's how i ended up
in prison anyway like someone burgled my
house
and then um okay yo no we're gonna talk
about that and then the
um child okay i have to write stuff down
to remind me um my
wild brain um so
what was it
we're talking about burglary you were
burgled
and you were telling me about how you
were burgled and and your imaginary man
so
when the um man comes
like a construction worker comes over
whatever plumber whatever
and they're like um okay so i'm here to
do the plumbing i don't know how they
talk
and uh can you send that to lauren
michaels that impression i just did
for my audition for snl here to do the
plumbing
um and uh i'm like hey
like i
my boyfriend's upstairs he's sleeping
it's always like he's sleeping it's just
he's a little hungover
it's always his little hungover he just
drinks a lot
it's like you know he's just gone like i
could have been like
he's on with tokyo he runs a bank
he's upstairs lifting weights why did i
sharpening he's
i'm like his wife hates it when
doesn't come you know so it's just like
a funny
i have not lived alone ever i
have not i guess i um i lived briefly
alone
when i came home but even then like
i i had like my my boyfriend who was
there i
don't love to live alone um
which isn't you know i like people and
i'm i feel safer
i want to talk to you about um how
you make people instantly funny and
uh yourself deprecating humor and like
what we do about it like you know it's
sort of like a little bit
the fact that people don't have to be
self-deprecating around me because they
can just be amanda deprecating
and they're allowed and a little bit of
me dies inside every time i do it and
because i have such a like
i think brain and i i've stopped
i do think i deserve an award for all
the ones i didn't the jokes i didn't
make around the knives
sure i've made how many knives uh jokes
have i made around you so far of like
amanda you can you touch the knife or
like i'm like where's the knife so i can
cut the tomatoes morning she's cutting
tomatoes
and i'm like you're like where's the
chef's knife yeah
i don't even know what the fuck that is
it's just the one that instead of a
paring knife to like slice him it's good
for slicing
anyway we're making you shakshouka for
breakfast and i'm like hey where's the
chef's knife and you're like you've all
the people to not know
and i said it i did i've done it i think
like three times
i would say and i think i've not said it
maybe like
but here's the thing like you that every
time i almost hurt myself
no i know it's a funny joke but it's a
little bit of me
dies and i wonder if a little bit of you
died like or does a little bit of you
heal
it's not that funny of a joke though
well so here
so there are jokes that are at my
expense that are just like
you know easy not funny jokes that are
at my expense and then there are jokes
like when i first came home
my family like had this cake and we all
were having cake and they're like man to
cut the cake and i was like you sure
about yeah yeah yeah yeah like those are
funny jokes
can i tell you the ones that that that
were funny
once but i think if we did it again i
wouldn't like it
is i not i wouldn't like it i would just
be like oh no no ow
like you don't have to do this like
you're you don't have to be amanda knox
all the time
is when um i
um i don't know i almost hit my head on
something or i was like
just don't hit your head on this thing i
don't wanna you know and you're like
yeah don't die when i'm in the house
or something yeah and that's like a joke
but also a little serious
yeah you're like please don't die if i'm
near you i think we were out here
uh uh no we were at the other place a
rental place
because they have those like fake beams
yeah and i and you were like please
don't die yeah no one's allowed to get
hurt or die around me
because i'll get blamed which is why i'm
a really cool person to have a round
because you could commit a massacre and
everyone would assume it was yeah yeah
yeah i actually think it's kind of the
opposite they're like what are the
chances that happen twice
people like have reached out to him or
my best friends
to say you need to get away from her
she's going to kill you yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and like uh i mean i guess the
one thing that like makes me sad is like
with the knife jokes
thing is it's like i'll and the orgy
jokes thing
is it's like not only have i never
killed anyone i've never stabbed anyone
and i've never been in an orgy so like
all these like jokes are once again
about like the idea of me that was like
totally fake and made up and like so it
doesn't even feel like the jokes about
me
because again it's just like everything
about me is not about it
that's why that 30 rock joke that was so
good
so good yes so they were like um
uh kristen shaw was talking about being
famous and she's you know kissing shaw
but not me no i don't know kristen shaw
she has made a joke about me on 30 rock
i love her
i love kristin i love her she's so good
people confuse me with her i get so
excited so i'm like oh you think i'm
funny
the best joke ever that i like just
loved was she was talking about being
famous and she was like are you kidding
me it's so easy to become famous amanda
knox got famous for
not killing excellent like that's
amazing and it's like yes thank you
it's sucks to be famous for not doing
something it's like it's like i told you
this i'm like it just feels like you're
still in jail just like a different kind
of jail
you know and granted i'll take this jail
yeah yeah of course of course
and then it's it's interesting because
you know your husband and i have had a
couple
is it row or row row not even
you've just had like a row like a little
like scuffle like a row
a row but not even you guys have fun
conversations
like like the kind of conversations we
should be allowed to have but everyone's
afraid to have because
everyone wants to assert their identity
through the things that they say and
they're never willing to entertain an
alternative idea
and in where i come from that's just
called an interesting conversation and i
would love to get in a conversation with
your husband chris with coming in with
one thing and come out and being wrong
and go oh my god yes just learn that i
re i just no
i know you know what words i'm not
hearing anymore i just realized and i
just
changed my i'm not allowed to i never
thought about it that way before
when's the time you heard someone say i
just realized something yep
no you're a bad person if you've never
thought about something before
um old specials okay so
and then you made me laugh really hard
this felt like it was worth it
when you uh i said something
because my personality like the
confluence of the
um quarantine and my mom got covered and
everyone's in isolation and we're all
at peak fever
and yeah fear and we don't uncertainty
in the future
the sun kills it the other day the sun
doesn't kill it one day the masks are
good and the next day you're taking them
from the workers yeah the next day
you're
yep um uh your blood type is the problem
and you know
yep so we're just in this terror
management
nightmare and i said something where i
was like i'm so
and but i've i've really leaned i think
during this time i've leaned into what
like kind of honoring the way my brain
works which is very
how would you describe it i mean you are
constantly entertaining a lot of
your your brain is your screen right
here which is like
a ton of windows open with a lot of
scattered thoughts that all
definitely have connections 58
922 underwrite emails exactly
but like you have a through line and
like sometimes it's hard for the rest of
the world to like
stay on top of it like we do have to do
a little extra work to be like okay
what horse are we jumping on right now
because you're kind of galloping
seven different horses that are totally
happy about being ridden
at the same time so it's like okay yes
so and like and you're so
and and so it's like two things can be
true at once yes
so i said something like i'm so sorry
sorry i'm being crazy
oh i said to you i was like sorry i'm
being so nuts and then i was like i have
lived i've been trapped in rooms and
lived with women who have killed their
own children
so i can handle you whitney
we are cool do you look like a
therapist um my therapist
is my journal and him and my cats
and the podcast and the podcast honestly
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's that labyrinth so okay so yeah
your podcast is which i do
kind of want it to be video i know we
just don't have the technology yeah
yeah like this is a beautiful setup and
i actually want to take notes from you
like which i offered
you can come down here once a month and
shoot five episodes
and also make a list of me for me of all
the things that i need yes because
i also want amanda to uh and chris to
decorate the studio because they are on
it they are i need to take measurements
so fucking
amazing with crafts it's wild and we're
not even the best people at crafts that
we know well that's why you're the best
because you think like that that's my
favorite type of person
well so learning process but i want um
i listened i don't want to get in
trouble with some of the guests that i
listened to but i was listening to it
and it's just you're so
unbelievably um
god it's like what i i just don't want
to insult anybody that unnecessary i
don't want to take any like unnecessary
jobs
but it's just so fascinating the way you
guys taught you're so incredibly is it
erudite or erudite
erudite eric
i'm just going to let you flounder
[Laughter]
i always get around erydite eryudite are
you trying to say
that we're you're so earned or what are
you trying to say so like you're just so
well spoken
so incisive it's it's for me i have to
be laughing or learning so are you
thinking eloquent
no it's just it's just okay fucking
erratic okay yeah i'm just
in i'm just learning something i'm just
like fuck but like
my favorite thing is having my mind
blown okay cool and your podcast
is a mind-blowing podcast well thank you
because i'm constantly trying oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i was so happy that you like i'll kill
you it makes me realize how many i'll
kill you jokes i make
right and you're not allowed i'm not
allowed to make that joke like
is it exhausting to just constantly have
to monitor
your don't kill me i'm going to kill you
i have a knife like is it do you
is it constantly running or not um i'm
going to respond
i mean i am aware that certain people
are going to be weirdly sensitive to
anything that i
say because simply because it's coming
from me i just don't know who those
people are
of course because like like i said i'm
walking through the world where there's
this like screen in front of me and some
people see through it and those
other people don't yeah and so like
everything i could possibly say
is perpetually tainted by people who
want to compare
what i went through to what meredith
went through and like so it's right
anyway and they just want a hit of the
self-righteous indignation yes i get a
lot of that i think
and you uh touched on it in the
documentary you didn't get paid for uh
to do
for your time um where you
said like people need a villain they
love mine you said people love monsters
we love villains
well they don't want to be the monster
themselves and if if it's it i mean
there's a very
uh andrew huberman i think spoke about
it on the podcast
of like how um you know
we're design we get uh our brain
releases dopamine
uh when
someone else is being castigated and
we're
judging them because we have protection
from the tribe and we get dopamine
and this is like a mind-blowing concept
that like these are the kinds of things
that i think
tell us about who we are and why things
happen to us and like the why for me is
the thing that always has bothered me
about what happened to me and what
happens to other people like
why were people putting like dicks on
all of your billboards
well that's a really interesting
question because it's either
people suck and which is a boring answer
also i was 15 i'd do it
it would be funny exactly and again like
is the 15 year old is going to have
a reason for doing it that 35 years an
underdog
thank you yeah 10 years to figure out
that's why we're such good friends yeah
i am irate
thinking about the students in college
right now
who aren't going to college who still
have to pay
yeah i i'm irate about people who went
to college and then don't get to use
their degree because there's no jobs and
they're still having to pay
the job they went to school for no
longer exists well it's just
how they don't get a job in a pandonique
so it's like
ernest is helping you out times are
tough and who wants to worry about
earnest let's say what it's not or not
it's not it's not some guy
it's not earnest the guy this is a
company that literally
is like your dad if he was an accountant
everyone's dream like he just
like ernest comes in yeah it's the
company who's not some guy but they're
like a guy
yes
basically offers you low rate student
loan refund
best characteristics of a man and a
woman in one
company compassionate yet good at math
yeah about you but can do percentages
and interest rates
i mean that is a great i mean there you
go that's the best way to describe it
they're going to help you refinance your
loans reduce your loans long time
terms save money with just simple
monthly payments they're just
you know that most these people are
doing get doing this because they can
get away with it
uh loans yeah these student loans are
student loans are evil that's yeah but
these 19 year olds should be taking out
150 000 dollars
not knowing they bank on us not fucking
knowing
what we're signing up and what we're
reading
you're like well that will get me
through this semester i'll buy my food
i'll have time for you know get little
treats and go out and then you don't
think
that when you're you know 24 and you you
you don't have no money for that and
there's a inflation
now what you loaned me a hundred dollars
but now i have to pay you back 200 that
doesn't make any sense
and the interest i could pay every day
and only pay off six dollars
did you see me just try to do math just
try to make money
earnest is now offering our listeners a
hundred dollar
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar
bonus re uh refinance your student loans
at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply once
again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus with a visit to earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com
whitney for more details terms and
conditions apply earnings student loans
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc
nmls number one two zero
four nine one seven california finance
license number six zero five four seven
eight eight
three three second street suite 401
north san francisco california nine four
one oh seven visit
dot com slash license for a full list of
licenses
okay the next one is a big question you
ever can get boners
whoa we got a roman ad roman
we got an erectile dysfunction solver ad
wait wait wait wait wait you don't
understand how big of a deal this is
benton
this oh my god i'm you i don't know look
roman i am obsessed with your company
and i'm about to say a lot of things
about you
and sell a lot of your products but
fact that you think i have seen dicks
that aren't hard
is shocking a little offensive first of
all they're around me
they're hard so but i'm happy
they're trying to use them as a shift
use my imagination
to say that i'm sure it's a very big
bummer
when you walk out in your fancy lingerie
you just bought and
nothing you get a thumb you know
i get that that's upsetting to some
women i don't know what that's like but
if there's a way to avoid that kind of
embarrassment
i'd say do it because you could end up
38 and single because you're too afraid
to be naked in front of a man
i don't know what roman is is they're
gonna help you
with erectile dysfunction easily
you're gonna get that joe rogan dick
okay that's what roman
gets you hard and you s you fucking
handle shit
real health care professional prescribes
you a real medication
free online evaluation ongoing care
comfort privacy could you imagine if
when you call in this is what the person
sounds like
real comfort care boners
like it's the one thing we have right
now is sex it's like the only thing
that is like a fun even if you're single
you still want to have a little boner
you know
just a little boner in the evening just
a little bone bone
a little breakfast boner you don't know
you can take your aroma whenever you
want to
that's true but i feel like if you have
erectile effects on your own you'll just
wait for it to come around
you can't you don't have to be ashamed
of it you don't have to blame yourself
roman you go online
yourself by the way all guys out there
if you don't get a boner we think it's
our fault and then we start crying
and you don't know why so get this yeah
and if i don't get a boner it's because
there's no mirrors around
go to roman.com whitney today
if approved you'll get 15 off your first
order of ed
treatment that's
getroman.comwhitneygetroman.comwhitney
and then once you get your prescription
call me
so i like to get my mind blown by trying
to understand how complicated human
beings are
and so i'm just perpetually trying to go
down those avenues to understand them
which means that i have to sit
uncomfortably
all the time with the fact that like
there are people doing bad things
thinking they're doing good things
and there are people who are doing bad
things and they just don't care
and there's a reason they don't wrong
things for the right reasons
exactly and doing the right things for
the wrong reasons
so there's this performance artist and
i'm not going to say her name
right who stands on butter
um we had to watch the whole thing like
the thing is i think too many people
just watch a clip of it
and they don't experience the whole
thing like you need i i feel like you
have to see
what it is so a woman who
showed this to you by the way had you
seen it no i had not seen it
you definitely showed it to me um just
like trying to
i want the credit and a man is like yes
what do you want oh oh yes
you have all the credit um
woman of color um slightly bigger build
is
um wearing a sort of tight very
you know what be sure like she's sort of
short black dress
wearing these kind of chunky heels and
she's doing
a on just like on a very plain stage and
she's just on some chunks of butter
and she is full 15 chunks of big
blocks of butter and she is digging in
her heels
into this butter as she's like dancing
and it's
like a seductive dance like she's kind
of i mean it's not like
making eye contact with the audience eye
contact in like painful
painful like vulnerable but almost like
broken sort of like i'm trying like i
need you to see
how hard i'm trying to like
be this person that i'm like i'm trying
to be
this person that's seductive i don't
know like for me it was expressing a lot
of like
deep anger but also like i think she's
challenging the audience uh
to
to laugh at her laugh at her and pity
her
and feel their own shame and feel her
shame and
if she was not corpulent
or of a bigger build or not the
traditional stand of
standard of beauty would this be funny
i don't think so because i think a part
of the comedy
is her body like the part like the fact
that she's
her she's literally flopping you start
laughing when she falls
yes and if this was charlie's there
and it looks like it hurts like it looks
painful
look if this was nicole kidman we would
be
very upset because is it because we
believe that the fat is protecting her
from being injured or we just think it's
funny
all right or we're just exposed to the
we're
almost numbed to the idea that like
fat bodies are you know pained
and like are you know flopping and like
falling on banana peels like it's just
funny so if we see
when you hear the audio it goes from
to laughter then back to and then people
start leaving like it's
but you would stay the whole time i
would i would feel
the need to be a witness
because i'm not going to just know that
she's in pain in that room
and she's sharing that pain with other
people
and i just decided it was like not for
me
yeah what did and what did you um
because i believe that a big part of
your situation
is we just want to watch you
we just people just want to look at
selfishly just want to look at you i
mean we are such
we are driven by our reptilian brains
and there is something about your face
they say asymmetrical faces are just
the golden rule of wanting to look at
someone well and also like especially
during the trial we're talking about how
i would cast you in a tv show and make
so much money you walk please
please i'm out of the business okay but
whatever
i do shows in my home with my friends
be on your show with my dog but i'm
saying if you walk into a room
a casting director the cw jen houston
um well not me if someone with my body
would walk
just in your face and you walk in
they're like we got her we
fucking got michelle williams we got
her who else uh emma stone we got her
right grandma stone i mean can't stop
looking at him
i am so bizarre i know it's bizarre to
me too
i hate you thank you for it i don't know
i mean it's it's
by the way um um sorry are you okay
don't be sorry
um uh who el julian
moore um who else uh julia armand is
actually
someone that really comes up for me with
you well and this was especially
interesting during trial because like
here i am i'm either
in prison where no one can lay their
eyes on me or
i'm in the courtroom where like
basically a life and death situation is
happening
so who's the uh in the odyssey helen
helen of troy yeah everyone's mad at
helena troy
who would play helen detroit today
um i don't know people's names i do it
but i don't think i've got i think alex
could do it
i think who would do it let's go
come on that uh alexandra daddario
a mogan poots yeah alexandra
dario would also play amanda knox bitch
did you see true detective yes i did the
first season that's you
show me again this girl is the most
like obsessed over girl got such pretty
eyes
that's you that's you amanda
knox chris you know what i'm talking
about no can you come over here
can you i mean that's her alexandra
that's like the samesies same same
i know i know i know about the face that
would launch a thousand ships
yes i think that's the face it's a big
that's a high bar
that is a very high bar i understand
that in a world when like there's only
like a thousand and two ships
but they they don't see that many
women's
all the ships
in your case the butt helps i mean
there's i didn't know about your butt
until i met you
um that was a plot twist um that was the
biggest plot twist in this case
i was like wait a second did everyone
know about her ass
this weird like junk in the chat so um
lady gaga you're in this just kind of
like
i feel like you're on the tarmac and
it's like
when do you get you're also not the only
person who said that
it's just like what are we doing i feel
like i feel less like a tarmac and more
like the glass ceiling is like
right here and i'm just going i'm not
even hitting it with my hands i'm
hitting it with my head
and i'm like and it's not like i feel
entitled to be on the other side it's
just like i have shit to do and i want
to do it
i'm just being held back it's like
you're in like you're like
fist fighting a sandstorm i always say
it's like you're just like it's like
there's no way to
and like i know it's weird i almost
wonder if like i'm
sort of making this happen because i'm
so i've spent my entire adult life
with people who have been opposing me
and wanting to
you know put me in a small place and put
me in a little cage and tell me who i am
and so i'm almost used to it and i get
confused when i almost am like
i don't know what's gonna happen when i
actually do have the opportunity to just
like
be a person and do what i want because
i'm constantly expecting people to want
to box me in i don't know anyone that
thinks you're guilty it's kind of funny
well i mean people don't like go outside
like people want
like people go it's like the sideshow
it's like the zoo
it's like i just feel like you're like a
zoo animal we were such a zoo animal for
a while
and now it's like there's there's plenty
of people who think that she's not
guilty but also think that
her role in life now is to disappear
quietly and respectfully because
any reminder of her existence is
re-traumatizing people
and using your fame off of that is
disrespectful
to you as if she somehow chose you're
not allowed to be happy you're not
allowed to have fun so
i'm not allowed to exist publicly
because
i am reminding everyone about who
doesn't get to exist the other
day you were at my house and you guys
were swing dancing
yes and you're an amazing swing dancer
because of the junk in your trunk
yeah a lot of people just stare right at
that
and say your face um
and you're like this amazing swing
dancer and i was looking at her you and
i was like gosh she's just such a
um it felt so triumphant to someone that
doesn't know you at all and so
cool and just
[Laughter]
and i just you're just like i was just
like no
people can't see you having fun no well
and then i
you know not giving a fuck what i'm
doing with my body has not always worked
out for me well but also i'm a little
bit stubborn
where i'm like fuck you i didn't do
anything like i really did not do
anything
i'm sorry um but i really didn't do that
like i don't even think you need to say
that ever again like i'm trying to get
like i'm trying to get you to never have
to say that again and i don't know
i want to be at that place like i hear
you and i want to be at that place it's
like when i go in an interview and
someone's like so it was like to be on
punkt and i'm like
what huh
are you sure yeah you don't even know
what i'm
talking about i know what punk is i've
seen the one where they did um
elijah wood and i was like oh elijah
wood he's like he just like cares
shot in front of show yeah yeah which i
love i mean which i made
it was my first job and i was like
you were you were that wasn't punked oh
i was like you were like
one of the you weren't like the punch
person agents okay you were punking
people you didn't get punked i did like
no i wasn't famous enough
uh i was uh uh i wasn't famous at all
which is why i got the job
you know a lot of people that were like
amanda knox is guilty and she did it and
she's hot and sexy and had an orgy
like it's embarrassing to have been
wrong and need to change your mind
and i think a lot we have and i think
this is
there's a biological basis for it but we
have this thing where we
are embarrassed to go you know what i
was wrong i shouldn't have done that
especially when i'm not a real person so
like for most
people just like because the way our
brains work i'm not a real person i'm an
idea of a person
so like i understand when people like i
was having this conversation with tig
notaro where like pig natara was like oh
yeah i totally thought you were guilty
and i feel really bad for it now
and i was like um recently i was talking
to
claire haynes and notaro um because they
did a whole episode
oh cheryl hines sorry oh yes on the
sharon heinz and tignetaro and they had
like done an
episode about the um my documentary
and i happened to listen to it and they
were like wouldn't be funny if amanda
was listening to
it and so i was like i found cheryl
hines on instagram and i was like hey
just you know
i did listen to it like if you ever want
to like if you have any questions like i
was just literally like
um you know it sounds like you have
that's it
in the case like it's a complicated case
and like the the documentary series was
only able to get into like the
fundamentals but there's like a whole
world
around the case that is interesting and
um and
you know anyway so i said like hey if
you have any questions like feel free
i'm an open book
and they were like oh my god can you
come on the podcast so anyway i came on
and tick was like i'm so sorry like i
just assumed
like everyone else that you were guilty
and not like everyone else
uh everyone people
all women all men like we get these
generalizations which build my house i
know
um get us really bogged down it's true
no i never i truly never thought you
were going but there is a sense
i like i looked at her and i was like
it's pretty
you're fucked if you look like you you
are fucked whether you're
in italy whether you're in perugia
whether in pensacola florida whether
you're in toledo like some it's just
like
which isn't to say that like pretty
women aren't guilty of things
how easy is it to decide that someone is
less human even when they're right there
can i give you the madness of crowds not
yet the book uh we have it
okay i've read it yeah you got it got it
got it no um i think he's
right about some things and a little
overblown about other things
because he has to filibuster
how many books have you written i've
written one um
he's written how many have you written
published two but
yeah and we also wrote a book of poems
together yeah nice
well we should all brought that it's
called the cardio tesseract it's
lovely i'm so sorry the cardio tesseract
it's love poems we wrote back and forth
i'll send you when we get home
they're exquisite what have you thought
about thought about a real fight
real fight uh like fucking don't
a real don't fucking do that again the
closest thing that we've really thought
about
is um so we work together and we create
together
and very often we have different
thresholds for
when we can move on to next steps um
and occasionally what will happen is
chris wants to assert a level of
perfectionism that i feel
is counterproductive um or like there
will be like
i don't know maybe i'm just a little bit
delicate and insecure but what else what
i'll interpret as him being like
this isn't good enough i need to make it
better is like
me thinking he's saying i'm not good
enough and so he has to make it better
and that bothers me but like we've had
conversations where i've had to be like
okay
this is not about me it's about the work
and about a level of perfect for the
podcast
podcast the stargate that we um made
like there are moments
for their wedding we'll get to it yeah
so like all these like beautiful things
that we make
there's always conflict in the process
of making because
my process is not exactly it's weird
it's just it's just we don't we don't
fight
we don't fight well we're just very good
at conflict resolution this is why i
love horses
as soon as something bubbles out of
control just a little bit yeah we go
okay something's happened yeah and we
we resolve the tension within 15 minutes
this is why i'm obsessed with
prey animals because they forgive very
they
forgive very quickly and they
look boom and we're back they don't hold
on to it
right you don't hold on to it but you
also don't have to hold on to it if you
say
here's how i'm feeling even if you don't
think that i'm justified in how i'm
feeling here it is
here it is we both acknowledge it's
there and then we
move on never go to sleep angry never
ever ever um i've heard that
you know friends never sleep fights only
happen when you don't address stuff and
it faster yes
and then yeah sets it off and then it's
a big fight
we don't let we don't let anything
fester yeah but you're also like
just like properly matched
it's like kind of shocking um
so
i wrote this down if you had
killed this person we would have
forgiven you by now
that's an interesting thought i mean
people seem to have forgiven the guy who
actually did it
and that's the other thing i'm sure
people talked about this like when i was
watching the um
documentary i was like oh he's black
that's awkward
yeah it is i like i like didn't want him
to do it
people have literally reached out to me
on twitter to say like
i don't believe you because black men
are always accused of crimes they didn't
do
and he's a black man so there must be
something wrong of course and it's it's
like fuck why is she pretty and why does
she have to be pretty
why does she have to be black and he
have to be black
it was just like the perfect fucking
storm shit storm
even the prosecution was bringing stuff
up like oh you know after they had
safely convicted him like he got
convicted long before
i did they were like oh now that he's
safely convicted we can say
he was just you know he was just there
he didn't really he wasn't the
mastermind like amanda was he's just
this poor black man
we really you know like it's really
amanda who was the one
who was like evil for the sake of evil
she was the luciferina she was the
do you have a cell phone in prison no no
no no
no but like what what so the second it
happens you give your cell phone because
there were like conversations in that
documentary of you talking
yeah so i until i was arrested like
arrested arrested like i was being
interrogated but i wasn't arrested did
someone hit you on the back of the head
yes
twice um was that that's legal i mean no
well they say it didn't happen but like
the what happened was in the four days
between
us discovering that meredith had been
murdered and me being arrested
i was not told that i was a suspect they
said that i was not a suspect in fact
it was never even like a thought in my
head that i could be a suspect
i was a witness and they told me that i
was a witness i was that they kept
saying you're an important witness
meanwhile they tapped my they tapped my
phone and they were interrogating me
and three hours over the
it means that all phone conversations
that i have are now recorded which is
all just
all ways now right i mean they're
legally allowed to like
put that into the the you know case
files oh god
yeah and that can then be in the news
however the only time that they didn't
record me was the final interrogation
where they actually
broke me that's the one time where they
were like oh with the budget we just
couldn't keep the recorders on
i know uh multiple men
who are in recovery programs now who
said the only way
they can come is if a woman cries
hmm
i just and these are not i mean i'm in a
12-step program admittedly we all know
that i can't believe it took me this
long to bring it up
um you know people wanting you to cry
is so fascinating to me because if you
did cry it wouldn't have been enough it
would have been too much she's overdoing
it she's underdoing it she's
sobbing too much she's faking it she's
meanwhile the emotions of anyone else
involved
including the person who actually killed
my roommate
never even discussed it's always what
i'm wearing
what emotions i'm expressing because
also her emotions are not even
you know her emotions they are a
product of media selection bias
you're also in fucking shock when i
i told you when my dog was getting
surgery i was ordering starbucks for
people in the parking lot
yeah and stretching you know this
association is a
is a way of dealing with a traumatic got
the call that my dad died i was at the
airport landed your dad died i went to
work
on roseanne uh nope
uh meeting at roseanne we were in
pre-production the writers weren't there
yet
and then i went to see my horse and then
i was fine i was listening to robin in
the car
uh call your girlfriend didn't tell
anyone
um got home got an email that said
we need to transport his body saw the
word body and it just
broke yeah and then the next time i
didn't cry
and then the funeral
never laughed harder than at the funeral
but also imagine i laughed i laughed at
the funeral my father's funeral i
died laughing if you recorded every
second
of your demeanor from for those few days
and then decided to cherry-pick an hour
of footage out of
hundreds of hours of footage it's just
you singing robin in the car it could
make you look like anything
we can make you look like the ideal
morning griever um
in prison were you ever um like harmed
or scared or like when you're famous
in prison that's a thing right yes so
so yes last year we had a little faux
pas because i was talking
my therapist like the people in prison
you got to watch the ones that are quiet
you were like that's what they said
about me bitch
yeah no it's true um so the guards would
say that they were like i
trust the ones that like you know i
trust the ones that are yelling and
screaming and getting into fights i
don't trust the ones
that are quiet um because i don't know
what to expect of them
and a lot of the guards would say either
oh amanda you're the ideal
prisoner or oh amanda you're the kind of
prisoner who
is unpredictable in both cases i was
like but that's because i'm not supposed
to be here
i'm literally not supposed to be here um
either way though like my
my approach to getting through the
prison environment and being the famous
one like being the famous one in prison
means that everyone feels entitled to
your fucking business
and not only your fucking business but
like the worst experience of your life
like here's the i am living through the
worst experience of my life
and everyone is entitled
to like get their little piece of it and
like have their opinion about it are you
showering with people
so i'm not showering with people um but
i'm definitely showering
exposed to people um
like i'm cold right now can i have my
yeah bolero
thank you for letting me borrow it like
uh i'm cold tell her about the vichy
come on
i'm cold youth i'm cold thinking about
you showering in italy in a prison
it was hard for me that you were in
prison
well you're empathizing i get that and
like um
so yeah it would go from like incredibly
cold
uh in the winter to incredibly hot in
the summer that it would it was better
on whichever side of the prison you
actually had like
air flow most people were not italian
most people were not italian
yeah most people were african
or romanian um
women young pregnant um
that was across the board there were
some people who were very young i was
one of the youngest
i went in at 20. there it is
i definitely still had all of my teeth
and that was unusual your teeth are
also a problem because they are perfect
perfect chompers never had i had braces
she loves to brush i do love to brush i
got obsessed with brushing in prison
because
i was used to getting you know a regular
dental visit every six months and then i
went to prison
and it was so funny because like when
they came by and they were like
you know dentist like the once a year
dentist is like and i was like oh i'll
sign up for the once a year dentist and
they were like what are you talking
about you have all your teeth still
and i was like okay but i went and then
the dentist looked at me and was like
why are you here like
i'm not here like you don't need any
teeth pulled and i was like oh i'm just
for my
six-month thing and he was like uh-huh
and so he just like sort of
like what was he like was he an italian
he was italian yeah i was like
italian or speaking yeah yeah speaking
italian no one spoke english
and you could knew what they were saying
well so the first
year of my time in prison was people
yelling at me because i didn't
understand what they were saying
and it was very scary because like it's
a thing where i'm like i'm just trying
to wash my
underwear in the bidet like you're
supposed to do also with your mask wash
your mask
it's like underwear that's true my ent
just told me that
you have to wash it all the time so
again i wasn't doing that i was it was
in my car it was in my purse i was like
i'm gonna
be green and now my snot is green
i succeeded anyway there were just lots
of things that i didn't know
and i couldn't even i had to work really
really hard
to like not step on anybody's toes
because everyone in there
is a broken damaged person who has
emotional triggers
and like you know i it's my turn to
clean the cell
so i am like scrubbing the floor and
someone's yelling at me because i
they don't agree with the way that i'm
scrubbing the floor i did not cry very
often you're just like
i went numb i went stoic i boxer from
animal farm
um is that are you impressed yeah i am
impressed boxer from animal farm
oh look at that yeah boxer i'm i'm the
kind of like just
trudge like okay here i am suffering if
i just like
i think i can i think i can i can just
get up this hill i don't know how
long this hill is how long did you how
long did you think you were going to be
in there it depends on the time of the
so before my conviction i thought that
at any point
someone would realize that something was
wrong and i could come home
like literally like at any point after
my conviction i thought i was never two
years in
until the trial resolved yeah two years
ago
two years of my imprisonment i thought
it's all going to work out anything can
happen
any day now someone's going to realize
that it's all wrong and they're going to
let me out groundhog day
and exactly and then after my conviction
everything i thought was true about the
world and about truth and what people
cared about
was demolished and you're seeing the
news you're you have newspapers
um so there are italian newspapers that
you could
like there's one italian newspaper that
you can get and they want to interview
you do you have to do it
no they did not have access to me um so
yeah i was like
under lockdown and that's one of the
reasons why it was such a a thing
to see me in the trial because i was
like under lockdown
you're doing the art of seduction by
robert greene by accident
yeah like i'm like i'm this sort of like
special hived away like princess jasmine
in like the
walled off court and then i get brought
to brought to the public display to get
like flogged that and everyone's like oh
so
well the you going through those crowds
those mosh pits was just so
hard for me
well you're empathizing like i mean
watching you go through those is it was
so
um
you just disassociate um
i mean are you bruised are you i mean
you look it looked physically
dangerous it is physically dangerous and
a lot of people i hate it when people
describe my relationship to paparazzi as
like a dance
it's like i know what i know how to
fucking dance yeah you know i saw it
and dancing is a consensual thing and
what's happening to me is an assault
like you were literally like
up on my body and i just like it's and
the police aren't
really helping there aren't really
barriers there's there's no
they don't legal it's not legal to
get in the way of the paparazzi
like does the paparazzi get money from
the government
it's the paparazzi they're they're just
more protected by the laws than they are
here
and it even here they have way too much
leeway i think but they're
paparazzi if you kill one it's like
self-defense here oh no no no you're not
allowed to like touch
if you touch their camera you're
assaulting them
like when we went back italy last summer
you know it was like
imagine like 15 people swarming around
you like
six inches from your face falling over
each other in order to like get
closer to you hurting themselves hurting
themselves in order to shove their
camera closer no i i've never and
cameras back then were weapons i mean
cameras
they were like cumbersome yeah you could
yeah watching it it's it's just this was
just six
that was recently um yeah where was that
when i went back to italy the first time
okay we'll talk about that but also you
flew into la a couple days ago
oh yeah well no one assaulted me i just
there was a lot
but i'm just saying there's paparazzi
for you a couple days ago here which is
just
that that was surprising because i was
like it's not
known that i was coming here i'm wearing
a mask and i walk
out of the airport and someone's like
amanda amanda with their camera and
their microphone
you could have been alexandra daddario
yeah like
why and like the fact that they said
amanda i was like
i think that i think that someone's
selling
names someone that works at the flight
office i wouldn't i
haven't i run that theory by you emily
yeah because
it's only when i fly one airline i get
paparazzi i'm like i'm not that famous i
mean
it goes to show like here's another
reason why we should have universal
basic income because
no one is getting paid enough to be
decent to another right
like we all have to sell each other out
we all have to do things out of
desperation it's like the po
it's like poaching in africa it's like
you're going to tell people they can't
kill a drought they can't feed their kid
right they're like giraffe for my kid
it's my thing about guns in america
people i've
i get in fights with all the time i have
i have family in virginia it's like
you're going to tell me
i can't protect my children and the
nearest
yeah and anyone who doesn't acknowledge
that is is
is making their argument like making
their even their whole purpose
it's the latest but it's also like
genuinely you're shooting yourself in
your own foot like anyone who's in the
like the criminal justice community who
doesn't like acknowledge that there
are victims who who would who would feel
so much safer
if anyone who committed a crime never
left prison again
and like i understand that impulse
because i've had something horrible
happen to me
and the fact that the person who nearly
could have killed me and who killed my
roommate is just like walking around now
it's like i would not want to live in
that town where he free
so he gets off on day release now and
like he's very very close to serving out
his
sentence because he got a reduced
sentence for not being the mastermind
he was he was convicted of rape and
conspiracy to commit murder
actually murdering marriage even though
his dna is like in and on meredith's
body his handprints and footprints
you know like it's obscene it's really
wild just when
you realize that the people that are in
charge
had moms that didn't love them and dads
that didn't love them and
you know are in debt and are scared and
have egos
and you're just like it's just such a
like a
it's a mind fuck well the traumas that
we experience become some of the most
real things to us because they're the
things that we keep obsessing over
i keep accessing over like why why why
does this happen to me
i also just feel like people use you now
that does happen um and sometimes
i allow myself to be used because i
understand that there is
a higher goal or whatever like
so and i love the innocence community
because they are so so careful not to do
that like
when the innocence project and the whole
network is very very
firmly takes the stance of like
exoneries have been through enough they
don't have to then be paraded around so
that we can make a better case in court
um those who do feel comfortable coming
out and telling their story like
thank you but like you don't you
shouldn't feel like you have to do that
um but a lot of exonerees like and this
and i feel this as well is it's like
if the only thing that anyone has ever
cared about is
whether or not i'm guilty or innocent of
a crime like somehow
also my own self-worth becomes wrapped
around like your obsession with that
question because
that's the feedback loop i'm getting is
it's like when i and
i'm here's like here am i or here i am
trying to like
make all these crafts and make a podcast
and no one gives a shit
but they do give a shit if we get to sit
around and talk about whether or not i'm
guilty
yeah like that is a feedback loop that
i'm telling like oh the only thing that
you care about me
is the question of whether or not i have
anything to do with this crime
like it's like it's so tricky because
it's like as a woman it's like
any woman sorry it's like when you're
like i know that
you my looks work for me i know you want
to
like i i can use play this card because
i
because of fucking human nature and i
don't want to play this card but it
works and what am i to not i mean it's
just such a
um rat king well and i and i realized
that as well where i feel like
for me being a you know a white woman
i'm much more easy on the eyes than a
lot of other exonerees who have spent
decades in prison who are
older now and like who like who haven't
spent time
you know being forced to be a public
speaker so there's not quite a star
well yeah i mean comparatively so i also
feel like this sense of
i need to be the bridge between this
like huge
gap of understanding between people who
have to go through prison like the
number of times that i
encounter especially women because women
are really really care
about the criminal justice system even
though it's not built by us or
for us and we are so wrapped up with
like how any one of us could become a
victim at any time that's why we have
our imaginary men when like the workers
come around we have imaginary men that
we inform them of like here's my
boyfriend
um we're we're obsessed with how we can
be
hurt and yes at all times which is when
um you know it's been interesting with
the pandemic when men are like oh you go
to the grocery store and you're i don't
know and i'm like we're like that all
the time dude the pandemic like i'm just
like i'm scared of everyone all the time
and you know scared of their judgment
scared about what they're getting do you
mean walking to your car at night
like what do you mean everyone's like
some in the grocery store like didn't
have a mask on and they got too close to
me i'm like that's us
we're always in that hyper vigilance
we're prey animals we're prey
you know so it's that is not and that's
my obsession with um
the fear of robots too when men are uh
terrified of robots it's like oh because
this is the first
thing that um you don't
that could kill you right the first
thing that's stronger than you that
might one day
actually that we're used to that women
are scared of robots you know what that
makes so much sense for why men
are obsessed with the terminator and
women are obsessed with true crime it's
the exact same
period and um
uh pathogen avoidance obviously
dodges blue man
it's like i don't need the terminator i
have you watching the show of me you're
the terminator
like oh my god this is what i say about
scientists that like study fear i'm like
just
ask a woman nine scientists are in a lab
studying what makes people scared and
i'm like just ask
us i'm in a very intense person
i'm i'm super intense and if and i
haven't always been like this because i
was
you know before i was in recovery for
codependence i was a shape-shifter and i
just was like whatever you need me to be
i'm going to be that you need me to do
funny you need me to walk in eggshells
you need me to be
um less funny so that you can be the
star like i just need to know what you
need you need to get you a drink you
need me to you know
get drunk with you like what is it right
right so everything this i had to figure
out how to placate
you so that which is so normal for women
to do
exhausting exhausting but it's just like
the way we wrote a book about it yeah
we're wired for harmony we're wired to
figure out our place which is why women
make to make other people feel better to
stop yelling
like women are fucking bosses and why
they
don't hire them because you are getting
points it just shit won't run better
because it's there's ten kids and we
need to know who's hungry and who has to
pee and who has to shit and who just
fell and who's hurt and
right you know um uh
i still need to find out what the study
was um
that women evolved to cry because men
couldn't read faces well enough
interesting so it's like i literally
need to be like
leaking if it could be blood it would be
blood but i can't leak blood out of my
face so i'm just going to like alert you
there's something called pathogen
avoidance which is
part of the reason that uh when i had
this robot
and i would expose people to the robot
men would be like
men were like it creeps me out like
people they would get like
like but does it creep them out because
they also kind of want to touch it
that's why my special's called can i
touch it because guys would say can i
touch it and then i'm like aren't you
the same guy that put your hand on my
lower back at a nightclub you never
asked me you're like why
that is actually really funny like i'm i
have to ask permission to touch
your fake body but not your real
body and when you're pregnant people
just like
yep yep you know it's just like it's
wild how
women's bodies are public property
unless it's a machine because guys
cars cars are she cars
hmm cars you can't you relate to this at
all chris
don't yeah you're no you're an outlier
do i think of women as property
[Laughter]
um i mean obviously that's been one of
the major animating
principles of human society since
humans created society i think that
it's hard to explain human history
without thinking about
this ever-present notion of women as
property explains a lot of culture
also why are species proliferated yeah
yep
you know like we gotta and that goes
back to biology it goes back to just the
epistemic gap that meant i'm sorry
stopped
what's epistemic uh of or relating to
knowledge
um like epistemology the study of the
study of knowledge right
what's a synonym uh just knowledge
so knowing something so there's a gap in
knowing and you're talking about
the progeny so there's like ontology and
then there's epistemology
there's scientific there's a study of
what we know about reality
right so like when it comes to sperm and
egg and when it comes to
um procreation the man
does no child comes out of the man so he
just has to hope
that it's his seed that was implanted in
that woman and that she was faithful and
so forth so i have no control
over her i got a big fight i got a
little bit of a
thing with andrew huberman about um
because i had read somewhere that men's
penises were uh
evolved to be scoop out the
sperm of the competitive dicks are like
that
cat dicks have apparently have like
spikes on them
and ducks if you've ever seen ducks fuck
oh my god ducks okay so ducks like ducks
the way that like
female ducks deal with the fact that
they are just raped oh my god
first of all they have to get raped
ducks get so rich
only rape it's like it's only like it's
like i'm a duck
man dogs get raped no no ducks like
literally girl duck is like
tooting along in the water a guy duck
jumps on top of her
puts his beak on her head and drowns her
while he takes stickers no no like she's
basically
like ah and he's like sticking his
corkscrew dick
into her vagina which has many avenues
to like
trick the corkscrew dick into not
getting into her
actual vagina like it's really
disturbing and i only found this out
because i went to a hotel where like the
cute thing about the hotels they had
some ducks that were in the fountain in
the middle
and then i saw a duck getting raped and
i was like
oh my god this is just really the most
upsetting thing but like what was that
like you cannot catch a fucking break
dude
but also like it's just like such a
reminder that like almost
all sex ever like in the history of ever
has been rape
do you know about toxoplasma no cosmosis
yes yeah it's when um
it removes rodents innate fear of cats
oh i've heard that that affects humans
yeah yeah oh
yes a lot and it makes you want to have
more cat risk
yeah the extreme sports people the cliff
divers yes
rock free climbers motorcycle this uh
evolutionary adaptation to help the
parasite complete its life cycle
toxoplasma can sexually reproduce only
in the cat gut and for it to get there
the pathogen rodent
host must be eaten so it makes
rodents want to get eaten by cats yeah
they just aren't afraid of them anymore
so they just kind of sit there and like
and they know they run up to them and
they try to get eaten by them yeah
don't get me started on worms the ways
that our minds can be manipulated either
by
chemicals or just plain what impact
neurochemicals so you are an adrenaline
junkies
dream me yep and it were
sorry we were in that time i'm
toxoplasmosis
this has been a wild episode so i
decided
why don't you let let this digest let
this all marinate process it all
and we're gonna have the second half of
the episode two more hours of wildness
with amanda freaking knox next week
it's even crazier i love you guys thanks
for listening
i should want to put out a four hour
episode like a psychopath i love you